ladies and gentlemen put your hands
together for governor voted to approve
the league's 22 team format to restart
the season in Orlando woge from ESPN
joining us right now from Sports
Illustrated our friend Chris Mannix back
on a program how are you Chris going on
rich you tell me we got hoops yeah it
was a near unanimous vote from I'm just
sort of getting some of these texts in
real time Portland I guess was the only
team to vote against I'm not exactly
sure why they're there getting into this
postseason scrum of a 22 team I played
to be in restart so yeah I mean they've
they've got a format right now I don't
think there I wasn't they have cross all
the hurdles yes I mean still have to get
the players on board they're going to
have I believe a call tomorrow to
discuss this format with some of the
leadership committee on on that side and
of course you know we have heard
publicly nothing and teams I've talked
to you if hurt very little about what
the safety protocols are going to be so
it's a certainly significant day for the
NBA but the work isn't done yet okay so
maybe Portland's more of a universal as
opposed to a Disney may be a term you
know maybe that one maybe that's the
theme park there huh that's a
head-scratcher man you know because
you're right I mean it is Noah Damian
Lillard basically said is I don't want
to come if I don't have a shot at the
playoffs by just playing out the string
and the way that they the the methods
that they approved did in fact put
Portland as if a season ended today
which is a phrase I've been missing
musing they would be in that in that
play playing format for the eighth and
final playoff spot Chris yeah I mean
that they're they're getting pretty much
everything they could have asked for in
this situation to me now you know like
like I said it just happened as I came
on here so I gotta find out the next
hour so but it uh it's interesting you
know that's pervy there's more to it
with yeah I mean there are a lot of
teams up the rich that wanted more than
just you know kind of eight regular
season games they'd like to follow
get 282 - you know fulfill some
television commitments and and really
make up some of the money that they've
lost along the way somebody that has
something to do with it again Portland's
owned by Helen Family which is among the
richest in the world so I mean it's not
a lot to make though Chris Mannix here
on the Rich Eisen show so based on your
your thoughts reporting what you were
hearing they only voted on a format and
a return and safety protocols health and
safety protocols are still being worked
on right now well help helping safety
protocols have to be negotiated directly
with the Union but you you can't sort
unilaterally sure make make that type of
decision so I'm sure they've got you
know protocols want to go through but
the particulars of them at least as of
you know 20 minutes ago when I was
texting with two general managers are
still very much unknown to a lot of
people that are out there so we'll have
to see how it's all going to come
together we players have resisted the
idea of being too isolated in that spot
and the NBA is pushed back some by
saying look there's only so many people
we can bring into this campus or bubble
whatever you want to call it before the
risk you know becomes so prohibitive so
there certainly is some some needle
threating to do in a situation like that
Chris Mannix here on the Rich Eisen show
them let's let's get into it how does
the schedule get made up of those eight
regular season games best you can tell
here Chris it's easy in the Eastern
Conference when there's nine teams
everybody plays each other once but in
the West I mean wouldn't you say it
would be an unbalanced schedule
certainly if one team doesn't play the
Lakers at all and somebody might have to
actually play them twice from what from
what I've been told and again this is
all very much a work I don't know this
to be true just yet long until one of
the plans that was talked about was to
go by your existing schedule right so if
you're Portland and you got your season
postponed on X date whoever you were
supposed to play next you play back now
that theme doesn't exist in the current
and being landscape to go to the next
one and since they're all going to be
located in one location you can do that
pretty easily so that seems like a
logical way to do it it just continue
with your season as it was going to
progress anyway so if you're you know
and going into this you know going into
the work stoppage Memphis faced with a
pretty tough schedule I don't have it in
front of me but I know their schedule
for the tougher ones down the stretch so
they may still have to face those themes
whereas some of these other teams that
are behind them the three teams or three
and a half games back they may be they
will that maybe have an easier way to
agent way to go and I saw you know
single elimination double elimination
conversation about about playing what is
that what does that mean so it would
just be single elimination if it's
multiple teams and then when it finally
comes down to who makes the eighth and
final playoff spot best two or three
kind of is that what it would be like
trying to really kind of imagination of
what was actually approved but there's
some kind of provisions in there for a
play in game if the ninth seed is within
a certain amount of games for the AC and
look that's a useful tool to have
because you know with if you're gonna
reduce the number of games left in the
schedule from I'm like I think it was 16
for a lot of teams down to eight you're
gonna have to create some some wiggle
room there so I think it's something you
okay they say like the Blazers finished
within two or three games of Memphis
that last spot it won't just be Memphis
get it they will have to play Portland
for that the right to go into the
playoffs and the same thing in the East
Washington I believe it the only thing
going as part of this format if they can
find a way within whatever in three or
four games I'm not again I'm not exactly
sure and there'll be some kind of
playing game with them and the team
sitting in the eighth spot Sports
Illustrated Chris Mannix two minutes
left with him right here senior writer
on the program so what's the next steps
next step at for me Chris you said
there's still lots work to be done
what is what's next here well it begins
with all this getting approved by the
Players Union and you know the NBA I
think has one strongest relationships
between the league in Adam Silver
Michelle Roberts at the multiple deals
in their time and their respective
positions Adam Silver and Chris Paul
that the union are incredibly close so
you know they've had ongoing discussions
so I've imagined and and I'll probably
speak the Commissioner Neelie on some
kind of call reporters later I would
imagine but they're they're very much on
the same page now it doesn't necessarily
mean that all the players will approve
it but I have to imagine that that
silver and and Roberts and Paul has a
pretty clear plan for how to advance
this thing forward or but it goes the
players that then it will may be a
rubber stamp but will will find a way
forward after that so the Friday call
with the players is the next step I
think in the next 24 hours we're gonna
learn about the safety protocols who's
going to be allowed who's not they can
start getting kind of wheels moving yes
toward getting you guys back in their
market yes because it seems like we're
not gonna have what we're seeing in
Major League Baseball
which is an argument over money
and issues that have a collective
bargaining agreement a tinge to it
because that that's on the horizon and
then historic levels of mistrust it
seems to me here the question will be
about exactly like how does this work
how much testing is there who is allowed
to come to Disney World with the players
what are they going to do once they are
done with a series or off day what you
know who how stringent will the testing
and and the quarantine be for those who
are helping you know staff this right
like that's that to me is where the nuts
and bolts of how to make this work is
gonna go down over the next couple weeks
with these with this plan Chris right I
mean the financial part is a little bit
easier right now because I mean the
league completely it's almost 80% of its
see
players that received well over 50% of
pay already so you're not negotiating
financial package for the players at
this point now no spinning it for next
season could definitely see more pre
breaking out it you know if you know
amongst these two sides if fans cannot
return expense that rather doesn't exist
but right now they're fortunate that
that's less of an issue than it's going
to be and and yeah it is it is testing
and it's you know getting everybody on
the same page with the logistics all of
it and getting players on board I have
no doubt rich they're in the next I
haven't talked that one player is said
to specifically specifically but there
are others that have kids about it
that you might see some some players
maybe even a few prominent players but
don't want to go like I mean everybody's
got unique situations right I mean you
can a player like you know Yanis who as
a new baby and I'm not saying Alex
wouldn't go but he's got a new style and
maybe that job in in the position to
travel down to Florida and spend three
months there no baby he doesn't want to
go maybe there's somebody with a
pre-existing condition of some kind that
we don't know about I mean I think I
think it's gonna come out in the next
few days and it'll be what type of
players and our players I believe before
I let you go Chris Mannix I can't not
bring this up um let's just say right
around Memorial Day weekend you and the
rest of the staff at Sports Illustrated
crossover staff created an all-time NBA
starting five I will read yours out two
guards two forwards to Center in a six
men you hear about this Christopher
Brockman do you hear about this one from
Christopher Maddox yeah alright the
guards backcourt Steph Curry James
Harden they're very good your frontcourt
Larry Bird and LeBron James around
Senate if Tim Duncan six man Scottie
Pippen there's a name missing here Chris
I don't know if it was a ten part
documentary about this gentleman um I'm
not talking about Scott Burrell
that was not all ten episodes about him
there's there's no Jordan on this list
Chris what happened there's nine by the
way the number of people who
like that but what that's all about
I look we were asked to pick a team that
basically would well the dream team of
right now and what I thought of that one
of the first things I thought of was
that I want a team that just done from
frequent range
I want all prolific scorers and follow
Jordans marvelous town she wasn't a
great three or Shira thank you something
in the low thirties at that time you
know and in the nineties it didn't
matter
it was great you could be that type of
player and succeed but the type of shot
that Thornton took back then like he
would never be allowed to take those
shots now like NBA coaches would make
one lap person contested middle a jump
shot so when I was putting on putting
the team together
I thought about pardon and curry both
scores yes give me them and the sixth
merit I want like the versatile
defensive minded playmaker questions to
being a second banana Scottie Pippen to
me epitomizes that see now here's a
problem party problem Chris is two guys
who love the NBA and Chris Brockman and
my social media grandmaster TJ Jefferson
who might be interested in your response
heard none of it because they were too
busy arguing with each other about it
that's honestly like I'm trying to
listen to you and peripherally I've seen
two of my guys just barked at each other
I don't even know what they're saying
try to pay attention to you that's
that's what happens when you leave
Jordan or feuless Chris you know I don't
it for me to some people but I love the
team that wins games by scoring a
hundred first points and I think I put
together that type of team I put
together a team of Gunners and with
Pippen coming off the bench as the
defensive stopper a playmaker I'm
comfortable with my group going forward
yeah do you say you're like Coach Taylor
your team's on the floor everybody's
coming at you like it's like the episode
that seemed from Hoosiers they're all
howling at you and you're like my team's
on the floor that's you're saying hey
you at us now morning ceremony tell you
this game part the better offensive
players and Michael short stuff I'm
gonna be back by handle any of this
defending your reasoning to TJ that's
what we were going back and forth a
handle it you can't handle it alright
before before I let him before I let
Chris go because I know you got stuff to
do and you track down the story ask the
poll question we have not unveiled a
poll question on NBCSN Oh would Mannix's
team beat the Bulls no no it's the Wrath
of Khan anniversary the release of Star
Trek 2 in 1982 so we went best movie
sequel Wrath of Khan Godfather to Empire
Strikes Back Terminator 2 oh man
Godfather - I'm going - good good good
options all the way around I don't feel
better like a horse equal like because I
can have a better conversation about
that the worst sequel thanks for the
call through thanks very much Chris
Mannix thanks thanks Chris you take care
of well chat soon hopefully with more
information as conditions warm with an
actual return of basketball that would
be great you got a rich you go that's
Chris Mannix hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here